so it's been a bad week for tommy
robinson
the home affairs correspondent lizzie
dirdin from the independent released
multiple stories
about him and about the abuse that she
suffered you know you claim you're very
confident you know
that there are these 109 verses in the
quran that says kill the infidel
wherever you find him i said no problem
you know
let's meet and let's talk about these
specific verses then this all led up to
uh may 2018 which was day for freedom
which is where tommy
yeah and loads of other people from the
international far right all spoke on
stage
it was a huge crowd um just talk us
through
what happened leading up to that event
and then on the day
[Music]
so it's been a bad week for tommy
robinson the home affairs correspondent
lizzie dierdin from the independent
released multiple stories
about him and about the abuse that she
suffered when he turned up at her house
at 10 o'clock at night threatened to
call her
husband a pedophile and said that he
would come back every single night
and this has started a huge conversation
online about the type of abuse
that people have been on the receiving
end from tommy over the last few years
there's people been speaking out about
it for the first time in the last couple
of days
and one of the most shocking cases of
this
is something that happened in 2018 to
ali dawa who joins me here today
what was your first communication with
tommy
firstly i want to thank you for having
me here
so sorry last time a year ago uh yeah so
the thing is with specifically tom
robinson i used to come across him on
youtube so social media you know
especially with the far right and
britain first uh going to specific
muslim communities
and bullying individuals things oh your
book says this book says that and you
know these
people don't really know what what's
going on you know so i found that a bit
irritating because i was like okay
that's not really fair and
me i i don't like injustice done to
anybody i don't if it's a muslim or a
non-muslim
so i was keep watching these videos and
i felt really irritated i was like come
on you know if we're gonna have a
dialogue let's have a discussion you
know
and uh i think i tweeted uh him on
twitter
tommy robinson and i said look let's
have a dialogue you know you you claim
you're very confident you know that
there are these 109 verses in the quran
that says kill the infidel wherever you
find him i said no problem you know
let's meet and let's talk about these
specific verses and um
it's when he said that there was an
attack in manchester
uh the attack happened in manchester by
one of these isis guys
um and i was i done a separate video of
drake so drake um done a uh
he was he was in a concert and he said
to somebody take your scarf off
so i think he's talking to a muslim girl
in the crowd who has a hijab one
and i thought that's what this respect
for so i've done a video to drake saying
that you know um
basically that's wrong you know and uh
etc
so um he he picked it up and merged the
two
yeah and i was like wow so i said to the
muslim audience
guys you should be going to these
concerts anyways yeah because there's
all kind of
things that are not permissible in islam
so he got that and he said look
he was warning people to not go to this
um
certain event because he knew that some
kind of attack was going to happen so he
merged the manchester attack
with the whole drake thing yeah and he
was calling me a jihadi and i was like
the hell like like how could you how
could you slander me like that because
the things you're putting my life in
danger now you know you've got a
maniac crowd that's watching you the far
right and um
we know what they could do now you're
putting my life in danger so i actually
called
the met police stating and i think i
heard you saying
yes yes he's clean people to think you
were involved
in the manchester bombing yeah yes i
will shoot this filthy mix if i ever had
the chance yeah they should be with you
within the hour
okay because you're getting serious
threats so yeah it just it just started
from there really
yeah and then this all led up to uh
may 2018 which was day for freedom which
is where tommy yeah and
loads of other people from the
international far right all spoke on
stage it was
a huge crowd um just talk us through
what happened leading up to that event
and then uh on the day yeah so basically
um
i can remember i heard that there was a
freedom of speech event happening
and uh there was a specific individual
who was going to speak there is
he's from a sikh background but he
supports the far right yeah
and the sikh community kind of said to
him look we've got enough to do with
them
however when i heard as a sikh is going
to be there and there and i think i
heard statements of you know
everybody's open to everyone i thought
that's good you know if it's open to
everyone i'm sure it's open to a muslim
as well you know
and i thought you know i treated a bit
of like a social experiment because i do
social experiments every now and then
so i thought let's see would they let me
talk yeah so i think i got in contact
with um
what's her name um lucy lucy i've got
contact with lucy
i i'll be honest you see all this
you see the organization from this
[Applause]
the videos
none of this and the people were
thanking me i had those people coming up
saying thank you for the day
i didn't do anything that's the truth
and i said look can i come like and then
she was like oh that's a great idea and
i think she spoke to george
and and then they said we'll confirm
we'll confirm but he said why not
yeah because i think you guys genuinely
believed what you you had principles you
believed in the freedom of speech so
i need to make a speech yeah and i'm i'm
not really good at like i did a lot of
youtube videos here but like speaking
with hundreds of people looking at you
it's not the same yeah so i thought okay
let me get the speech ready so i
called muhammad hijab and we went to an
internet cafe near his house and then
we were just putting this together and
then we wrote it all down
um and i thought like to me i was like
oh man it's gonna be it's
it's nerve-wracking in it um so i
thought anyways we'll go
and i thought you know we've been
invited if we was not being invited
it's it's wrong for us to go there
because it's a hostile environment you
know it's silly
to go there and um just you know provoke
even though
us being there might provoke people but
we was invited so yeah we're invited
and i'm on the list you know and there's
some youtube videos by some other people
where my name is on the list and i was
official so me and hijab
we woke uh we went through the other
side
and then we walked past it was calm i
thought you know just walking past the
crowd we wouldn't make your life to the
other side but
it was okay some people were like oh
that's ali and i was like yeah i'm
talking and i was like okay i'll just
ignore them i just walked on and then
one of the security came and he's like
um
ali what what are you doing here i said
what do you want to do now i'm invited
you know
uh i've been invited to a party and i
want to tell you what you're doing here
and um i said i'm i'm going to speak
they're like no no you're not
hey
they're just talking to each other and i
started to realize there's an infight
happening
you know there's a definite in fact
happening so
they said wait here now when you're
making us wait behind the barriers
that's dangerous to us because we want
to be at least in the barriers yeah
and their security even though those
security might be with the same people
who attacked us rather than protect us
um so they said wait here we said okay
we'll wait here
and then we'll wait in our way in and we
don't hear nothing from there onwards i
realized that basically
as far as i know tommy was told that
basically
this was told to me directly that if you
let him speak
he's not going to leave that stage
meaning he's going to go up but he's not
going to come down yeah
and they said to him basically you're
not allowed to do that
so tommy obviously knowing he's he had
to throw people under the bus
and you can see that they were just you
know hostile everyone's hostile always
having debates left right center
you know when things were turned back on
them because i was saying look you you
calling me a pedophile yeah i'm so sorry
like i'm not trying to be generalized
here but i said most pedophiles look
like you you know i'm so sorry
midway uh white man i'm not saying all
of them but i said if you're gonna use
that on me
and then they didn't like that so it was
getting hostile it was getting hostile
and um yeah and then from there onwards
uh what we saw was that basically i'm
not allowed to come in
now that's well and good but now when
you're crowded
they're surrounding us yeah these fog
they're drunk they're showering abused
they're swearing
now how are you going to get out you
can't get out of there you know you go
they're going to follow you
so so yeah they were just uh swearing at
us and
lucy just said to us look when i say
three two one
just go like basically you follow the
security guard and just go and i said
okay i told the same to hijab
and that's exactly what we did but what
i didn't realize is that as we're going
i'm thinking okay
behind me we're going together like
we're just getting out here i didn't
know that
the attack happened behind me because
everyone's shouting anyways
so i went to the other side of the stage
and hijab was being attacked on this
side
and i was just i was just standing there
and i was just thinking oh my gosh my
like i don't know if they have a knife
what were they going to do
but thank god the offices came and
surrounded me and took me you know
yeah and that's that's what happened
it's a crazy story because i can confirm
you were invited
right up until the moment that you
turned up you're on the list
we really really pushed for it yeah i
mean for so long
people like tommy have constantly pushed
that the left are the real wide violent
ones
it's it's islamists it's communist it's
antifa
and it